all right let's jump into this first
story many of you have already seen the
videos released by Tucker Carlson but I
want to make sure we can remind you just
just a quick bit before I show you what
Whoopi Goldberg had to say about this so
we have Chuck Schumer bald-faced lie
attacking Fox News for shameful use of
January 6 video how unfortunate Elon
Musk roasting them which we'll show in a
second
and then we have the actual uh more
video footage showing exactly what
happened in this tweet from I just saw
this in response someone this is a Tony
bag of laughs tweeted if you think
Tucker Carlson is a liar it's because
you don't understand buildings have four
sides the capital is massive one side
was chaos the other side had cops waving
people in and assisting them inside
that's not punching cops and breaking
windows and here is a video showing
police opening the doors and letting
people in the video footage released by
Tucker Carlson shows
you've got the Jake chansley the guy
with the shaman hat or whatever you want
to call it being given an escort by
police who attempts to open doors for
him and show him around and then escort
him to the Senate chamber where he then
says thank you police
now in response to Tucker Carlson
reporting on this the media's gone nuts
that the GOP establishment has gone up
Mitch McConnell's losing it the
Democrats the media that's all they can
talk about and Whoopi Goldberg had this
to say
wait let's get the audio up can you
switch the audio over is it good
why why is this not being scrutinized
the way that they scrutinize other yeah
well thanks because to me this is this
should be against the law you should not
be able to lay to lie to the American
knowingly and you know it's one thing if
you made a mistake and you didn't know
but we heard for five or six years how
you know the media was the lion second
dude they were fake news they were this
so how come what is that what is our
what do we do as Americans to to say
this is not okay to the first amendment
I think you well no the First Amendment
doesn't allow you to willingly lie
the First Amendment actually does so you
know I'm not one to care too much about
the view to be completely honest but
this does exemplify a serious problem
that we have in that
yeah Whoopi maybe it should be illegal
to lie willfully to the American people
and then I gotta tell you you'd probably
be the one in jail it certainly would
not be Tucker Carlson probably be more
like Chuck Schumer don't get me wrong a
bunch of Republicans would be wrapped up
in it too but no the First Amendment
does in fact allow you to lie yeah
because there is no Arbiter of the truth
when it comes to government or at least
there shouldn't be but they're trying to
make one the scary thing about this is
and the reason why I think it's a good
lead story
Tucker Carlson got actual video evidence
showing
to be honest a lot of what we already
knew there's so much video footage of
people walking around in fact let me
show you how Elon Musk responded to this
and I want to play you this video
so Chuck Schumer says speaker McCarthy
has held the gavel for less than three
months but by sharing the January 6
security footage of Fox News he has
already done more than any party leader
in Congress to enable the spread of
Trump's big lie
Elon Musk responds do you want us to
remove this video and it's from Stephen
voiceover I will now play for you this
video and I hope you have a good laugh
[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the U.S Capitol building if
you've joined us today for the
Insurrection please make sure you pick
up a promotional leaflets on the way in
stay inside the safety cordons at all
times and if you get lost speak to one
of our Capital police officers they'll
be sure to point you in the right
direction
[Applause]
obviously this is ingest voice over
showing video footage of people
peacefully walking through the capitol
staying within the the the the security
ropes asking police for help and being
given help by the police
it's fascinating it's all oh there's a
guy taking a selfie he the video does
show people climbing the wall people
walking in the building
the funny thing is
if you are as the left would describe a
right-winger whatever that means you're
probably well aware that there was
violence on January 6 and you're
probably not okay with it I don't know
some people probably are but the left
keeps saying
Tucker's fans and Trump supporters don't
know about it they're lying and they're
outright saying on TV they want it to be
illegal to tell the truth because the
truth is actually the LIE they say but
don't trust your Your Lying Eyes we can
only just see the video footage from
Tucker Carlson here's the issue they
don't watch it they watch The Daily Show
they watch The View the view in The
Daily Show then lie about it and they
never actually see the evidence
so what do we do
I even like Whoopi gold Goldberg was
almost on to something she's like it
should be wrong to lie to the American
public meanwhile she's not aware of the
irony of what she's saying right like
well keeping some information and then
saying like well that's a lie she's
caught she is like right on the cusp of
realizing how almost getting it almost
getting it but she's not quite there
right I I um I mean I'm probably not the
one in the room to speak to this but I
think it's crazy that so many people
will just deny this exists right like
NBC's head headline for this right now
is like he's uh falsely depicting the
January 6 like events of the capital
it's video from the capitol how can he
falsely be be falsely depicting it
they're they're betting on people not
actually watching Tucker Carlson just
seeing the headlines when they say
falsely depict I really feel like it's
just just saying that he's he's you know
putting out a narrative that doesn't
align with ours because the video isn't
doctored or anything right it's not it
they'll say it's selectively edited well
I mean there's 44 000 hours so yes it is
selectively edited because you have you
can only put up so much uh material but
it doesn't change the fact that he's
showing video of what happened on that
day but he's presenting a different
narrative and the the left just can't
have anyone that doesn't fall in line
with what they're they're prescribed
narrative is it excites me so much to
see that tweet where the guy made the
point about the four sides of the
building because yeah so I was actually
placed on house arrest and I got out I
got off of house arrest for January 6th
in May of last year and literally within
a week of getting off of house arrest I
began doing media I was so anxious to
get out and start talking about this and
tell the story because nobody was
presenting a counter narrative nobody
and the first interview that I did was
an hour-long sit-down with Tucker on um
on Fox Nation and this is the point that
I was trying to drill home time and time
again when I kept doing my interviews
there were four sides to this building
and unless you were on the west side of
the building which is the side facing
the National Mall you were not seeing
people assaulting police officers
scaling walls breaking Windows when I
arrived on the east side of the building
the two large Columbus stores on the
east side of the building were already
open and people were saying people are
going inside the building you know so I
walked up to the top of the stairs stood
outside and shot a video for eight
minutes they ended up arresting me FBI
stormed my apartment handcuffed me took
me to jail when I got out I found out I
was facing multiple felonies and a
misdemeanor I never even went inside the
building on January 6th but when I got
out I found out I was facing multiple
felonies and one of the felonies against
me
was occupying restricted grounds it's
peculiar because most people who inside
the building actually got misdemeanors
of misdemeanors of occupying a
restricted building I got a felony for
occupying restricted grounds but the
point of this is that I'm considered an
insurrectionist I am considered a part
of the deadly Insurrection of January
6th even though I was on the opposite
side of the building but people don't
get this is what they don't want you to
know and this is why they've created
these narratives in the plea deal every
plea deal that you read from a January
sixer is going to include language
talking about how they knowingly did
this and they did this with this intent
and they were there to you know what I
mean it's and then they get to go to the
media and say well we have you know a
thousand convictions of people who have
confessed that they were there to
interact or to uh to disturb a
congressional hearing to disturb the
peaceful transfer of power everything
that I've heard about the confessions
and stuff like that sounds incredibly
maloused it sounds like they they you
know the the confessions that are given
to the people for plea deals and stuff
because that's how you get a plea deal
you have to confess right they sound
atrociously Maurice well they write it
for you yeah it's it's you they write it
you sign it and um it's one of the tools
that they're using to secure plea deals
is this charge called a felony
obstruction of Congress now this is so
they've never used the charge in this
way before
um it's got some sort of historical
context that has to do with uh people
intimidating Witnesses in a case in the
1970s but they they bent it and
contorted it and twisted it inside out
to use it for January 6 to say well you
know there was a congressional hearing
happening and it had to do with the
transfer power so we're going to apply
this felony charge of obstruction of
Congress which potentially carries 20
years in prison so you've got you know
felony for standing on the grounds and
felony for this and potential felony of
obstruction you could be faced I was
potentially facing three decades in
prison or I could take a misdemeanor for
disorderly conduct I chose the latter
and sign the plea deal yeah
that's what's going on do you find other
people are coming to you saying that's
exactly my experience oh 100 I mean
almost every person I know who took a
plea deal
has shared the same experience of going
into a very dark depression
um I actually just did an event at CPAC
that we called the true stories of
January 6th um which was a panel event
um featuring Dr Simone gold John strand
Jerry Perna the aunt of Matthew perner
who committed suicide who was also
facing a misdemeanor charge but chose to
kill himself rather than go through with
the rest of his sentence because the
government came to him and said now that
you've signed our misdemeanor plea deal
which would have carried about a maximum
six-month sentence then they chose to
tell him we're actually going to request
a terrorism enhancement to your
sentencing so now you're facing 60 years
in prison not six months they told him
this after he signed the plea deal Jerry
Perna was on our panel um and Derek
Evans and Derek Evans also took a plea
deal and talked about how he you know he
wept he cried when he signed it uh
because it's it's devastating
coercion really I mean all of these I
can't say that but um you know what
choice would you I'll say it I remember
I I often tell the story about how I got
uh
uh I got arrested for driving on a
suspended license that I didn't know was
suspended because in Illinois when
you're under the age of 21 if you get
more than one moving violation more than
two moving violations within I think two
years they suspend your license I got a
bunk ticket from a cop who claimed I was
speeding when I wasn't
didn't have the money to pay it off or
go to court or whatever didn't know
about the law and so when I get pulled
over and get a ticket I end up going to
court
and the judge said were you coerced in
any way and I said yes your honor and
then the judge freaked out and he was
like what by who and I was like the
prosecutor threatened having to go to
prison for a year unless I pled guilty
that's not coerced I'm like yes it is
yeah are you kidding me I'm like I'm I'm
out visiting my my family because
because I got a brother in law who's in
it who's in Iraq and my my family's
freaking out because they're always
going to lose his life I drive out there
drive back also I'm getting arrested for
suspended license I don't even know
because I wasn't even here it happened
like a week ago now you're telling me
I'm gonna go to jail for a year over
this yeah that's coercion sorry yeah and
then he was like go talk to a lawyer and
come back I'm sorry dude when a
prosecutor goes to any person and says
we are going to give you the maximum a
terror charge we are going to beat you
and torture you that's coercion right
we've got unlimited resources where the
federal government you're an individual
of limited means it's it's David versus
Goliath and we're going to hit you with
all of these charges oh and by the way
we won't transfer jurisdiction of your
case so you're going in front of a judge
jury who hates Donald Trump who hates
anybody who voted for Donald Trump we're
not going to let you be seen by a jury
of your peers to make the decision or
all of this can go away if you sign this
piece of paper and take this misdemeanor
plea deal which is um we're still going
to treat as an act of terrorism thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time